De la telescoape la Large Hadron Collider
fiecare nouă unealtă științifică inventează, revizuiește întrebările
pe care noi, ca oameni de știință
și minți curioase, le putem pune în mod rezonabil
calculul de înaltă performanță sau HPC
a intrat în acea listă de elită în anii '60; astăzi
calculatoarele cuantice bat la aceeași ușă.
Bun venit, mă numesc Iskandar Sitdikov
și sunt inginer software aici la IBM Quantum
în acest curs ne propunem să îi învățăm pe studenți
și pe profesioniști cum va colabora în curând calculul cuantic
cu infrastructurile HPC
pentru a oferi putere computațională
vei învăța cum comunică calculatoarele cuantice
și cele clasice și cum fac schimb de date
cum să scrii programe care exploatează ambele tipuri de hardware
și cum această integrare deschide aplicații pe care le putem rezolva astăzi
vei acumula experiență practică cu hardware cuantic real
și clustere de calcul de înaltă performanță clasice
rulând joburi cuantice alături de sarcini HPC tradiționale
și să știi cum să interpretezi rezultatele cu încredere
și să identifici locurile unde accelerarea cuantică
ar putea ajuta cu adevărat calculele
și unde nu; mai presus de toate, vei înțelege
încotro se îndreaptă viitorul calculatoarelor
și harta veche care ne va duce acolo; credem
că acest curs este atât important
cât și oportun și credem
că îmbinarea acestor tehnologii va fi esențială
pentru a obține avantaj computațional
acest lucru ar putea avea impacturi largi în industrii
precum chimia, permițând posibil
un design mai rapid al medicamentelor și cercetarea materialelor
în finanțe
pentru modele de risc mai inteligente
și detectarea fraudelor, în inteligența artificială și machine learning
pentru optimizarea modelelor; în acest curs
vom explora în profunzime resursele computaționale
modelele de programare și algoritmii cuantici
deci bun venit și pregătește-te
avem mult de discutat